[Music]
how
lucky can one guy slater than let's go
dude go do it
she'll be here any second man make it
romantic i'll play the dinners you
set the
oh next level pedaling gus
[Applause]
[Music]
why did you choose a mini from a charlie
brown thanksgiving because it's the only
thing they had at the gas station guys
come on
son don't don't answer that
i couldn't if i wanted to my phone is
even worse now none of the buttons are
working well we reap what we sell
she's coming okay uh i gotta get the
candles you sneak down the fire escape
cool wait fire escape
i am really proud of how you've handled
all of this
it was big of you to bail on lasseter's
case especially with goblins on the
table
thank you but i also know that you're
not sold on the guy who confessed to
shooting lassie but babe your neck is
way out there on this one
sean spencer are you the one worried
about me sniffing around where i
shouldn't be that's right feels good to
be the adult in this relationship
just this once yeah seriously though
please
promise me that you'll let the locals
handle this one
of course of course that being said i'm
gonna take this list i'm gonna do all
these errands for you which include
polishing lassie's rod but first i'm
gonna wrap both of us
in your favorite green snuggie and we're
gonna be in there for a while
it's in the big dresser drawer with all
the bedding
what are you doing that fire escape was
steep showing come on man
it's been a couple of hours look i told
her all afternoon that you were gonna be
gone now you've turned me into a liar
again you are a liar your dad's a liar
did you tell her about the hand no
because the hand is unimportant because
we're off the case now give me this damn
snug
stuff
what's that nothing hon
hey babe it's weird i can't find the
snuggie but you know what
we don't need that particular snuggie
because
is that gus's ringtone that
is gus's ringtone isn't it he must have
left his phone here
silly black goose i just remember where
the snuggie is
it's in the bedroom but it's deep i
think there's a depth to it will you go
look
for it you just want to see who's
calling so you can decide whether or not
to pick it up
will you marry me only if we can have
toast and jelly beans for dinner every
night deal
this is it that's where it's at this is
home base yep
yeah good god man turn that off stop
trying
it's woody i'll answer it he's got the
hand i thought you said the hand wasn't
important where are you gonna need your
grandpa
don't worry about that
guys first of all thank you for the
delicious smoked meats
he ate the ham he didn't need the hand i
put some smoked meats in with the ham
what would you do because it was 26 to
mail the box while it was full or not
gus i thought you of all people could
appreciate that level of frugality
woody i have good news and i have bad
news uh the venison
scrumptious oh also there was a uh
usable print on one of the dead guy's
fingers i got a name for the victim
some hot shot manufacturing ceo named
devon
tailback okay okay what's the bad news
sean the buffalo was chewy
tasted a little bit like fingernails
that makes sense it was actually tough
don't [ __ ] buffalo okay damn it now
we've got a real murder case and a real
victim
oh no no no he wasn't murdered or
dissolved by a witch he
committed suicide suicide yeah about a
week ago
jumped off a bridge into the san diego
river thought he was never found until
now i guess
luca no no sweetie
butterfly's baby is playing with a
spleen again i should go
yeah you should huh this is great
there's no ghost
it's opening shut what the hook no cuz
this is bad
suicide a hand turning up behind the
hospital where lassie's seen ghosts come
on jules is gonna go right back down
there when she hears all this stuff
we have to save her from herself what
does that even mean it means we go back
to santa barbara and start lying again
be careful for spiders
here comes the tickler
you